hello and welcome to the new world of
your source for everything anime and
manga and more specifically welcome to
the encyclopedia where today we will be
examining one of the most underrated but
undoubtedly phenomenal nin users in the
series being moral machanasi and yes
moral does indeed have a last name in
fact
lots of hunt hunter characters have last
names even hisoka his name is hisoka
moro which yes
is underwhelming and meaningless but hey
there it is but back to mr morrow when
it comes to hunters he is probably one
of the finest we've ever seen which does
include members of the zodiacs primarily
because i guess we haven't really seen
much of them but moral is very much the
embodiment of what it means to be a
hunter which in turn makes him the very
model of a modern major
end user and if you dear viewer wish to
sign up for moral six week intensive net
training program then all you need to do
is register your interest by subscribing
to the new world review which has the
added benefit of uploading regular hunt
hunt content straight into your youtube
feed but as for what you will become
though look moral is not an easy being
to live up to i've explored this idea on
a couple of occasions in previous
encyclopedia entries but there is a
certain physical and mental standard
that one must reach
in order to become a potent vessel of
aura control and whilst moral certainly
does not represent the pinnacle of
either in the series he
is indeed the king of consistency across
the board in terms of physicality he has
pushed the limitations of the human body
to its extremes resulting in incredible
strength speed and surprisingly amazing
reflexes which were on full display
during moral skirmish with chito as
moral quite quickly became accustomed to
chito's absurd speed but all of which
would be next to useless without an
equally a sharp mind to make use of
these physical abilities and in that
sense i would not place moral on the
same sort of intellectual playing field
as say
jing or paristan but in terms of combat
it's very hard to pinpoint a better
thinker and on-the-fly strategist but
most importantly of all moral does his
best to remain grounded at all times
in fact he is acutely aware that even
with all of these incredibly strong
features he could be defeated and
potentially even killed at a moment's
notice by a significantly less
experienced adversary simply due to
underestimating them and being surprised
by a weird nun ability and that thought
process is quite a rarity actually most
men users of morris caliber carry some
degree of arrogance or at the very least
far
far too much confidence with them into
battle whereas the name of marl's game
is versatility he is a man experienced
enough to know that anything is possible
in this world of our control and his
abilities reflect a desire to respond to
quite literally anything that gets
thrown his way
before launching into that though moral
is one of the very rare characters in
the series who provides us with an
accurate aura metric as according to
knuckle one of moral students he
possesses an aura pool consisting of
roughly 70
000 units what does units mean well
unfortunately it's a knuckle exclusive
measurement but it is consistent and
this can be directly compared to mr gone
who knuckle also measured in his
peak condition prior to the palace
invasion gone was capable of generating
twenty one and a half thousand units of
aura thus giving moral more than three
times the access to aura that an already
quite terrifying gone had
and the only thing that really
empirically eclipses morals aura
quantity is out of the royal guard the
ant king marawim and obviously isaac
netara although when trying to classify
them it's usually easier just to state
that their aura is effectively infinite
because their pools are just that
ridiculously large but all of that
really is to say that moral's aura
reserves are envious to say the least
and quite possibly his greatest
individual asset at most
as for someone who strives to be
prepared for anything and everything
a lot of leeway is going to be essential
in order to ensure that moral doesn't
lock himself into a dead end of or a
dedication now moving on tomorrow's
actual netfinity he happens to be a
natural manipulator which i think is
actually quite initially
counterproductive tomorrow's mission
with nenus i mean manipulation is
admittedly far more versatile than most
people give a credit for and that's
because when we think of this affinity
the mind always wanders to certain
characters like gillamy zoldick or
perhaps even
shalnok of house no last name both of
whom are the post children for pure
manipulation
in fact at no stage at any of their
abilities even credited with anything
else despite my insistence that emission
would be necessary in a couple of cases
but even if it was it would be a minimal
splash use of a mission and moral is
very much the exact opposite of this
when it comes to net moral investors
aura equally into three differing
affinities being manipulation emission
and transmutation which is a very
bizarre combination and extraordinarily
difficult to pull off but as a result
moro becomes a troublesome opponent and
nigh
on impossible to overcome which leads us
quite nicely into marl's crowning
nenability which is named deep purple
and the basic gist of this is that moral
is able to use his incredible quantity
of aura to create these smoke-based
constructs
which can take the form of items such as
ropes rafts grass like literally name
any
item any at all and maura will be able
to create it out of smoke but in
addition to that he can also create foe
nene beast by which i mean constructs
with the illusion of life that morrow
then goes on to manipulate
and this latter feature is probably what
most fans think of when it comes to
moral specifically his smoke troopers
however there is a pretty extraordinary
degree of confusion regarding how they
are brought into being which to get into
let's start with the smoke itself
because that presents a pretty big
problem
because this smoke is no smoke at all
it's actually transmuted aura which is
where a lot of the confusion surrounding
deep purple stems from the primary issue
being that moral as stated earlier is a
natural manipulator which if we examine
the nen ring
is generally incompatible with
transmutation due to them being in the
exact opposite positions so usually it
would be incredibly unwise for a
manipulator to try and dip into
transmutation because their aura cost
per mileage would be absolutely abysmal
and destructively inefficient
even for someone with morals ground
reserves however there is a surprisingly
simple way around this which is by
adding a restriction on the use of
transmutation and in moral's case that
would be the gigantic f
off pipe and in order to activate deep
purple or in fact any smoke-based
ability moro can only transmute aura
through this pipe via the process
of essentially smoking his own aura only
with that strict limitation can he use
transmutation to an efficient degree and
i would imagine that the size of the
pipe also plays greatly into these
limitations as well and if moral had say
an even bigger pipe then the
transmutation could be even more potent
however he went about as big as he
reasonably could to keep himself
versatile but i should mention that a
great misconception within many
hunthunter fans is that moral smoke is
just regular smoke that he goes on to
manipulate which to be fair does make
some straightforward sense with his
affinity as a manipulator but it's just
not true moral's aura smoke demonstrates
too many bizarre qualities that natural
smoke is simply not capable of for
example in his fight against leo moral
smoke is able to act as a solid
substance and form a series of
underwater pipes
and manipulation is just not capable of
such a thing you cannot manipulate
something to bend the laws of its
established reality
however what you can do is transmute an
entirely new substance that mimics smoke
whilst also providing other beneficial
features like how hisoka's bungee gum
contains the properties of both rubber
and gum there i said it and it is
neither substance yet both at the same
time all thanks to the power of
transmutation the best i could really
see one doing is coming up with an
explanation that moral uses real smoke
and then invokes enhancement on the
smoke to solidify and tighten the
particles or whatever which you know
isn't the most outrageous thing i've
ever seen or heard in hunt hunter
however it is a much more complicated
solution to a very simple nen problem
and in the end it doesn't matter anyway
because we do have confirmation when we
see morril's process of constructing a
smoke trooper so firstly what happens is
moral emits a ball of aura very standard
emission
almost exactly what someone like razer
would do except this ball is not meant
to serve an offensive purpose you could
think of it more like a computer chip or
some other programming device but this
aura nucleus is what moral issues
commands too which are then performed by
the smoke figure formed around it which
speaking of step two here has more quite
blatantly stating
then envelope it with smoke aura and i
really don't know how much clearer we
can get here here moral is stating that
his aura and the smoke are one in the
same thing so a transmuted substance
there is no other option which then goes
on to become the shape of whatever moral
wants to create and only then does
marl's primary affinity of manipulation
come into play which is then used to
issue commands to the aura nucleus
within it really is quite a genius level
use of none in my opinion because
manipulators and conjurers tend to get
quite screwed over in the world of hunt
hunter due to being right next to the
unusable specialization affinity which
is why a lot of conjurers and
manipulators will stick to more pure
based applications because of the
limited splash potential but morale just
took full advantage of the rules of men
deciding to take on a cumbersome but
workable restriction in order to have
access to an almost completely unique
skill set
there are further limitations though
specifically on deep purple and when it
comes to the smoke troopers moral has a
maximum capacity of crafting 216 of them
which yes is a hell of a lot but in this
case he is sacrificing quality for
quantity and it's really only useful
when he requires a show of overwhelming
force or for quick efficient scouting
purposes now alternatively morrow can
compress this number down to 50 troopers
which are capable of performing more
complex commands and they can even take
on more realistic forms
in fact to the untrained eye and even to
the trained end user they can pass for
living things because at this point even
an experienced nen user's end cannot
tell them apart from regular humans but
one problem that should also be
mentioned is that once moral has created
smoke troops or indeed smoke anything
his aura is then committed to that
construct and in order to retrieve the
aura spent he needs to dispel them which
can leave morrow quite compromised in
situations where deep purple is heavily
utilized although once again this
usually plays in tomorrow's great
advantage of our reserves he can very
much spend exorbitant amounts and still
have enough left to defend himself
quite effectively against well most
opponents anyway maybe not so much say a
member of the royal guard which brings
us to the second
and indeed final of marl's named
abilities actually which is known as
smokey jail
which at first glance just appears like
another unique use of deep purple but
the important technical difference is
that this ability does not utilize
emission it's just manipulation and
transmutation
coming together to form an unbreakable
barrier of smoke thing to encase someone
or something in
theoretically unbreakable anyway because
as it turns out due to transmuted smoke
still inherently possessing many of the
core qualities of smoke particle-sized
objects can still pass through the
barrier which is very awkward since
during the palace invasion moro was
faced with the one opponent who could do
exactly that it's still a ridiculously
powerful ability though however it may
come with at least one restriction being
that moral must also encase himself in
the smoky jail and it also likely
requires a truly massive investment of
aura to keep up due to there being
nothing but speculatory limitations
because it's just way way way way too
powerful to be used in a casual manner
and that's very much moral quite
possibly one of the most well-balanced
end users in hunter hunter someone whose
natural affinity of men did not
necessarily
agree with their path forward in life
and so someone who managed to use their
minds like no other because in theory
really moral is nothing all that special
we've seen stronger characters we've
seen smarter characters and we've
certainly seen more naturally talented
characters but moral makes his mark on
this world simply through hard work and
merit and really i think a lack of that
gone and killer
style talent may actually work very much
tomorrow's advantage because it has
forced him to think very creatively
about his various restrictions in life
resulting in one of the most captivating
nen users in the entire series but what
do you guys think please do leave your
thoughts in the comments below or even
join my discord server and if you're
keen for some more hunt on content then
please to go and check out some of my
other videos or even subscribe to the
channel for regular hunt on to glory
delivered straight into your youtube
feed but for now this has been the new
world review
and i'll see you next time